Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at how commercial
airplanes keep a steady supply of fresh air
and how the emergency oxygen masks supply
oxygen given they are not hooked up to any
air tank.
Let's get started.
Because the economics of having large oxygen
tanks aboard airliners simply doesn't work
out (not to mention that the air quality inside
the plane would rapidly become unpleasant
if fresh air wasn't constantly supplied, regardless
of the oxygen levels), commercial airplanes
have a very clever system installed to solve
the problem of ultra-low pressure atmosphere
at cruising altitudes.
In most modern airliners (the Boeing 787 Dreamliner
not withstanding), outside air is "bled off"
from the compressor stage of the turbine engines
and eventually piped into the passenger areas.
However, a bit of processing is needed first
as the compressed air is extremely hot (on
the order of nearly 400 degrees Fahrenheit
or 200 degrees Celsius) at this stage.
Thus, before it enters the passenger compartment,
it is first allowed to expand and is run through
a heat exchanger and air cycle system to cool
it off sufficiently.
This system also can work as a heater, with
some of the hot air mixed in with the cooled
air to regulate cabin temperature.
Once cooled and filtered, the pressurized
air, which now has sufficient oxygen density
to keep people happily conscious, is piped
into the cabin area, usually at levels around
12 psi (about equivalent to atmospheric pressure
at 7,000 feet).
Why 12 psi instead of something like sea-level
pressures of about 14.7 psi?
12 psi is sufficient for the majority of passengers
while simultaneously reducing the structural
strain on the aircraft itself over something
like sea level atmospheric pressures.
As for the air already in the cabin, this
is vented out through an outflow valve (or
multiple valves in larger aircraft), usually
located near the rear of the plane.
(Fun Note: Before smoking was banned on commercial
aircraft, the area around this outflow valve
was generally stained dark brown from tobacco
smoke.)
This outflow valve opens and closes automatically
to maintain a steady pressure inside the cabin,
while the entire system is ensuring that fresh
air is continually being piped into and eventually
blown out of the aircraft.
In fact, while many complain of airplanes
seeming "stuffy," this system ensures that
all the air in the aircraft is being completely
replaced on average every 2-3 minutes.
Yes, that means that your car, house or office
is likely significantly more "stuffy" than
a commercial airplane flying at 35,000 feet.
(Note: the Boeing 787 Dreamliner handles cabin
pressurization a little differently, using
a modernized version of the old, somewhat
inefficient, electric compressor system seen
on many older aircraft.)
Unfortunately, sometimes planes lose cabin
pressure.
Whatever the cause, the loss of pressure (usually
set at atmospheric pressures past 14,000 ft)
will result in oxygen masks deploying.
From here, useful consciousness may only last
as little as 5-15 seconds, depending on remaining
cabin pressure, which is why it's critical
to immediately put your mask on, rather than
helping someone else first.
You can help them much better when you're
not unconscious or dead.
So how do these airline oxygen masks actually
work?
It turns out, the economics of having a centralized
oxygen tank to provide even emergency oxygen
for passengers likewise simply doesn't add
up.
Similarly, having tiny individual pressurized
oxygen tanks also isn't feasible.
In fact, these masks aren't hooked up to any
tank or air line at all.
So how are you able to breathe oxygen through
them?
Science.
While designs can vary slightly, in general,
when you pull on the device to place it over
your face, the tug on the mask's lanyard releases
a spring-loaded mechanism that sets off a
small explosive charge.
The resulting spark triggers a mixture of
lead styphnate and tetracene to generate heat,
which will eventually cause a chemical reaction
that produces oxygen for your mask.
(This is why they tell you to tug on the mask
to get the oxygen flowing- you've got to set
off the explosive charge to get the whole
thing going.)
That's right.
What you breathe through the mask didn't begin
as pure oxygen.
Rather, the plane is equipped with numerous
small chemical oxygen generators (also known
as "oxygen candles," about the size of a small
package of tennis balls) which contain a mixture
of mostly sodium chlorate (NaClO3), less than
5% barium peroxide (BaO2) and less than 1%
potassium perchlorate (KClO4).
When these chemicals are heated by the lead
styphnate and tetracene, each undergoes a
reaction that ultimately results in a fair
bit of filtered, life sustaining oxygen running
through the tube to you.
Of course, you might also smell a faint burning
odor, but this is nothing to be alarmed about;
it just assures you that the system is working.
In fact, if the plane is actually on fire,
the masks usually won't deploy, so as not
to make the fire worse with the extra oxygen.
This brings us to the question of why the
plastic bag on the breathing apparatus won't
necessarily inflate as you're using the device.
More than just cosmetic, the bags serve as
something of a reservoir for oxygen.
If you aren't taking a breath at all (and
have a good seal with the mask tight against
your face) the bag keeps the precious, continuously
flowing oxygen from escaping into the thin
air around you, enabling more of the collected
oxygen to be taken in when you do take a breath.
When this is happening, or you are breathing
out with the valves on the mask releasing
much of the used air, the bag may begin to
inflate as oxygen collects.
When you breathe in, it will deflate.
So why won't it always inflate at least a
little to show its working?
To begin with, you may not have a great seal
with the mask on your face, particularly if
you have facial hair.
This will allow any produced oxygen (and air
you exhale) to more readily escape.
(As long as the mask is reasonably secure
on your face, this should still provide you
with sufficient oxygen to get by on as long
as the plane isn't flying above 40,000 feet
and the pilot does his or her job and gets
the plane down below 10,000 feet as rapidly
as safely possible.)
Even if you have a good seal, however, the
rate at which the oxygen is generated is often
not enough to fully inflate the masks' bag
before you take deep, potentially panicky
breaths, deflating it.
This is simply because the oxygen generation
isn't on-demand (for the passengers anyway),
but simply a continuous-flow production of
oxygen.
Despite the potentially slow production, the
chemical oxygen generators do provide oxygen
at a sufficient rate to sustain passengers,
generally designed such that peak oxygen production
occurs right away (when the plane may be at
very high altitude) with the oxygen production
rates tailing off over the course of approximately
12-20 minutes before the system burns itself
out.
This should be long enough for the pilots
to get the plane low enough so that the air
pressure is high enough for (relatively) normal
atmospheric breathing.
And if you've ever been lucky enough to be
in this sort of situation, you know that those
pilots can get the plane from altitudes like
35,000+ feet to safer atmospheric levels alarmingly
quickly in an emergency; while it may not
be literally true, it at least can seem like
roller coasters have nothing on them, which
is a good thing in this case.
Bonus Fact:
As a result of the way the system works for
pressurizing the airplane cabin and keeping
a steady supply of fresh air, the humidity
levels are ultra-low, making it so you dehydrate
very quickly on flights.
Particularly for long flights, it's critical
then that you drink plenty of fluids.
This ultra-low humidity level, combined with
the low cabin pressure, also reduces your
sense of taste and smell by as much as 30%,
which is why airline food generally tastes
so bland.
To try to compensate for this somewhat, many
airlines make sure their food is much more
strongly flavored or spiced than you'd normally
find appetizing.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.